conosco francesca sul treno qualche mese
fa
scatta subito della simpatia e quando
scopre che collaboro con un'associazione
dei consumatori
mi racconta la sua storia
francesca e stefano si sono conosciuti
al liceo lei è una brava studentessa lui
è ricreato ribelle intelligente a 17
anni sfidanzato
finiscono il liceo vanno all'università
si laureano trovano un lavoro un certo
punto un giorno al mare inaspettatamente
stefano le chiede di sposarla
vanno a vivere in città in una casa
d'affitto mettono da parte dei soldi e
una sera con gli amici si raccontano ai
propri sogni
una dice vuole diventare uno scrittore
importante l'altro dice vorrei comprare
un bimbi
l'altro ancora io vorrei vincere al
superenalotto
andare a vivere a formentera e stare
tutto il giorno con un costume di paglia
noi
vorremmo comprare la casa dei nostri
sogni
la casa una casa piena di sole col verde
intorno
l'altalena l'amaca
una casa isolata
un giorno vedono l'annuncio sul giornale
stavano vendendo delle villette a
schiera fuori roma
c'è il numero di telefono chiamano
risponde una persona socievole
e fissa una visita
vanno
la persona che li accoglie è di mezza
età
disponibile e gentile vedono il posto la
zona giusta il prezzo anche
guardando la casa
soggiorno
lì ci vedo la cucina aperta però lì la
camera da letto
lì
una stanza dove mettere il pianoforte
e poi c'è anche un'altra cameretta
magari un domani cresce la famiglia
l'accompagnatore nota l'interesse e fa
subito presente che c'è un'altra coppia
che vorrebbe acquistarla
ecco il sogno sta per sfumare
ma l'accompagnatore tira fuori dalla
tasca un modulo lo compila e lo consegna
a francesca e stefano
loro lo guardano è scritto fitto fitto
parerà maico che fare vi siete mai
trovati in questa situazione
me l'hanno raccontata come va a finire
franceschi stefano prendono tre giorni
gli chiedono di aspettare in fondo
l'altalena l'amaca possono aspettare
anche tre giorni ma perché francesca ha
chiesto tre giorni
perché si è ricordata che giorno un suo
amico un suo amico avvocato gli ha detto
mi raccomando
non firmare ma nessun impegno perché poi
è difficile tornare indietro
mi presento
sono laila perciballi un avvocato anche
referente di un'associazione dei
consumatori
noi tutti abbiamo un sogno il sogno più
grande è la casa
anch'io quando ero ragazza ho sognato la
mia casa e mio padre mi ha aiutato
ringrazio ancora mio padre
che cosa mi diceva mio padre
mi raccomando non avere fretta la fretta
è una cattiva consigliera se quanti
enormi ci sono dietro una casa
norme tributari donne civili norme
penali norme amministrative
insomma bisogna davvero stare attenti
quando ci si innamora di una casa e come
quando ci si innamora del proprio uomo o
della propria donna si perde un po la
bussola
inebriati ubriachi e voi andreste mai in
giro da ubriachi sicuramente no
se dovete andare ad una festa e pensate
di poter bere un po di più certamente vi
mettete d'accordo con un guidatore
lucido che vi accompagnerà a casa senza
smarrirvi senza metterlo in pericolo
e allora anche per la casa bisogna
affidarsi a un professionista esperto
professionista che vi accompagna alla
realizzazione del vostro sogno
perché come fare
bisogna fare un preliminare o un
compromesso con il preliminare
entrambe le parti si impegnano sia
l'acquirente e sera compratore
il destino di una casa è datato come ha
fatto il preliminare e sono indicati i
termini il prezzo e modalità di
pagamento
tutto è indicato nel preliminare e si
differenza della proposta d'acquisto
perché dell'una si obbliga soltanto
l'acquirente che mette a disposizione il
nostro ma di denaro e il venditore è
libero di fare quel che vuole
il compromesso invece no entrambe le
parti si assumono degli obblighi
ebbene se proprio non si può fare a meno
di fare la proposta da questo allora
possiamo tranquillamente utilizzare
delle accortezze
o
diamo un termine molto breve
e poi e poi dare una caparra minima così
male che vada si perde poco denaro e in
ogni caso un termine breve il venditore
dovrà decidere in fretta e poi si può
mettere d'accordo e fare un nuovo
preliminare in cui si individuano meglio
le cose da scrivere ma il premier e ci
salva proprio da tutto
no
è possibile che il venditore possa
iscrivere ipoteca se troppo immobile o
possa venderlo a qualcun altro in quel
caso l'acquirente ha solo diritto al
risarcimento del danno e si può fare
qualcosa per evitare questo
per evitarlo si può dar luogo alla
trascrizione nei registri immobiliari
del preliminare e chi lo fa lo fa il
notaio
ecco
che cosa deve contenere un preliminare
la prima cosa da vedere è se il
venditore può effettivamente vendere
l'immobile
perché è possibile che venditori non
possa farlo certo bisogna verificare se
il venditore è l'effettivo titolare e
per fare questo è necessario risalire di
vendita e vendita nei 20 anni precedenti
l'acquisto dell'immobile
solo così si può essere sicuri e poi
cos'altro vendicato nel preliminare
vendicato l'immobile e quindi va
descritto bisogna indicare la via il
civico il piano i metri quadrati
i dati catastali e poi
e poi
quante domande
quante cose da sfere
bisognerebbe fare altri talk oppure
studiare tanto o meglio affidarsi al
professionista esperto
certo sarebbe bello ho visto la casa la
casa dei miei sogni
mi è piaciuta ho conosciuto al
proprietario
ci siamo scambiati la mano e poco dopo
il trasloco è fatta beh non è così
bisogna affidarsi a un professionista
esperto per non perdere la bussola e
quindi mi raccomando
utilizzate tutte le accortezze
e ancora grazie